[Music]
winter is coming and the ocean is
freezing
we're out here on the first sea ice and
we're hunting for a seal yeah
[Applause]
I'm in a tiny village in Greenland where
the sun is just coming back after a
winter of Darkness
and yet the ice around here is at its
highest point
I'm actually on an island but no boats
are getting in and out of here anytime
soon
I've been moving through Greenland
trying to get to Villages and
settlements that are impossibly far away
Villages like this dot the coast of
Greenland
settlements of people living impossibly
high up on the globe living on these
rocks that are spilling off of the
world's largest and iciest Island
[Music]
I set out to go to one of these
Northerly villages
to try to understand what happens to
them when the ice closes in and their
world transforms turning from liquid to
solid cutting them off from the world
but also opening them up to walk on
water
so let me introduce you to a place that
many don't know much about Greenland
a place built on deep Traditions but one
that is facing rapid change
[Music]
I'm in this Village in rural Greenland
the sun just came up after a very very
dark winter it is negative 30 degrees
and I am trying to make it to a small
island up the coast of Greenland Here
Comes our airplane
we're taking that little plane but
that's just the beginning of our
adventure here
[Music]
well that was a stunning flight jeez now
it's time to get on a helicopter
foreign
[Music]
we made it to this island called umanak
it's impossibly far away and impossibly
beautiful we still have one more leg to
go to get to the Island village that we
are trying to get to but the map doesn't
actually look like this right now it
actually looks much more like this
everything's frozen
lucky for us we can just walk on water
are they sealed yeah seal skin gloves
and this is polar bear oh wow
[Music]
so now we're just cruising on
the sea ice
towards the village
during our ride along the sea ice we
stopped to feel the Silence of this
Frozen landscape
the local who is Towing me in his sled
told me that I was lucky that this ice
was just barely thick enough if I had
come just a week earlier I wouldn't have
been able to ride over the ice 15 to 20
years ago we can freeze already from
October all the way to end of June but
now nowadays the first maybe February
okay shall we continue yeah let's do it
we continued on our way and after an
hour or so in the distance I could see
the village that three days ago I set
out to find
[Music]
we pull into the Frozen Harbor of this
Village of 200 people okay this is
and I remind myself where I am I'm on an
island a settlement perched on one of
the scattered rocks off Greenland's
Coast deep in the umanak Fjord system
450 kilometers north of the Arctic
Circle
[Music]
the amount of time and energy it took to
get here was my first lesson about life
on the ice but this was just the
beginning
[Music]
first thing I want to know about this
place
how do they get their food
that's what we will figure out tomorrow
morning
I got to do something really important
right now sitting out here in the middle
of like this deserted field but I need
to thank today's sponsor
um who made this really ambitious
resource intensive video possible the
thank you nordvpn for sponsoring today's
video and for supporting tons of our
videos like nordvpn has been a supporter
of this channel for like years now and
I'm very grateful but also I like to use
nordvpn like I'm using it here on my
trip now like I connect to the internet
via the United States so I can watch all
my shows or connect to all my accounts
without getting like kicked out because
the internet thinks I'm in a different
country when I'm back home and not
traveling I also use nordvpn to connect
to the internet via other countries so I
can access streaming platforms for
better prices access shows that aren't
available in my country it's just a
really cool simple tool that's just like
one click away it's not complicated at
all you don't need to know anything
about how it works to just click a
button and be connected to the internet
nordvpn has become much more than a VPN
though they are now a threat protection
tool that allows you to surf the
Internet in a way more secure way so
they have a suite of tools that encrypt
your traffic while you're online that
blocks malicious trackers or annoying
ads basically just makes you much more
secure while you're surfing the internet
which more and more these days is
necessary all of this is wrapped up into
one really smooth product so that's
nordvpn there's a link in my description
clicking that link helps support this
channel you should go click it but it
also gets you in on a really good deal
for nordvpn you can get the two-year
plan for a really really good price as
well as a bonus gift that they're going
to throw in who doesn't like a good
bonus gift am I right so go to that link
it's nordvpn.com Johnny Harris thank you
nordvpn for sponsoring this video this
adventure this wild insight into a
different world I'm very grateful for
their support let's get back to this
adventure there's a lot to see we are
here in Greenland exploring
[Music]
after my first night in this Village
called satut I woke up to the dim winter
light and could see this place clearly
this is an island a small one three
times smaller than Central Park
most of the year it's surrounded by
water reachable by boats from the
outside that brings supplies but during
the darkest months satut gets locked in
it is now cut off from shipments from
the outside
[Music]
the ice gives them access to new ways of
living new ways of hunting
and that's what I'm going to see today
we're going hunting with Nikolai
a local here is going to show us what
this looks like
we're having a little pre uh hunting
breakfast here wow amazing thank you
Nikolai and his daughter are about to
take us out hunting for the day he
immediately realizes that we're gonna
need a couple extra layers to keep these
Outsiders warm up
oh
now equipped with the adequate
insulation for the negative 15 degree
weather Nikolai and his daughter were
ready to take us out onto the ice
[Music]
so we're going to get to the dogs now
yes oh great
[Music]
so all of these are your dad's dogs yeah
your father's dogs
[Music]
there are really strict rules about dogs
you can't bring dogs up here of any kind
from outside only the native sled dogs
that have been here for Generations are
allowed to be up here
and that's because these dogs are a very
specific kind of dog that for
Generations have been a vital part of
the survival of these communities in the
winter
[Music]
putting on the heavy duty stuff here
because we're just out here on the ice
all day and it gets cold
[Music]
all right it's finally time to see how
people live out here during the winter
[Music]
moving over solid water on dog sleds is
what Inuits have done for Generations
as I rode with Nikolai we couldn't
communicate much because of our language
barrier but one thing he made clear is
that the ice used to be a lot thicker Ah
that's how thick it was before the ice
was much thicker before but right now
right now this ice how thick like this
yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you
today Nikolai is hunting for seals who
are at their plumpest right now and
thanks to the winter ice Nikolai can set
up net traps around the edges of giant
icebergs where he knows the seals will
swim
foreign
[Applause]
so we got a seal using an old Inuit
trapping method in hunting grounds that
are only available for a few months out
of the year the same hunting grounds
were not long ago another seal was
caught and turned into food and clothes
so your your pants are made out of this
the seal the same type of seal that came
from this type of trap wow are they warm
yeah so yeah really well I was surprised
to see Nikolai started burying the seal
in snow
foreign and this is where I realized how
much Nikolai and I thought very
differently about ice
as we headed to another seal trap I
thought a lot about ice for me ice is
just frozen water that allows me to cool
down a drink or ski down a mountain but
for Nikolai in his community ice is
infinitely more important
what's he doing here
moving these small powder of snow to
make it clear so you can see the way
that he handled the ice used it as an
anchor cut it shaped it the number of
nuanced statements he made about the
Ice's Behavior
foreign
we get to our next seal hole and Nikolai
quickly deduces what's happening under
the Frozen surface just from a few hits
with his shovel
we dig despite the extra layers of ice
that Nikolai somehow senses
I see it
and eventually we make it through
another seal maybe a pair of gloves
with a long glance into the distance
Nikolai then tells us that our time is
limited
[Music]
with a couple hours before the blizzard
comes we head to another Island to look
for tarm again
an Arctic bird that is a delicious
staple during the winter
during the hunting we interacted with a
lot of what looks like a bunch of ice
and snow but for Nikolai his daughter
and their Community this scene is
actually full of dozens of types of ice
each of them with their own behavior
their own purpose sea ice itself is its
own category with its own set of words
thin sea ice is different than thick sea
ice the ice around an iceberg that
Nikolai was studying is also its own
category its own word there's a distinct
word for this ice hole and a verb that
means to chip away at the ice that
formed in this hole overnight this ice
chunk anchoring nikolai's rope has its
own word as well there's a different
word for flat ice and newly formed ice
uneven ice and old ice Inland ice fresh
water ice slushy ice there's even a word
for the Deep sound that ice makes when
it moves and cracks
the word for cracked ice is distinctly
different than the word for the actual
cracks themselves which is also
different from the verb for moving
through a narrow passage of cracked sea
ice in a boat there's a word for this
The Edge where the ice ends and the
water begins there's even a word for the
Crusty sharp ice that forms on top of
snow and a word for the water created
when snow melts on top of sea ice and I
could go on
[Music]
I'm learning a lot about the behavior of
ice had no idea how complex it was
this Rich vocabulary is an indication of
how alive this Isis for these
communities it moves and creaks it comes
and goes it provides the ground to find
food and then it takes it away learning
to speak the language of the ice is a
must for a community like this
struck by how how he's able to navigate
out here like these icebergs are not the
same ones that were here last the season
they're they're changing every day
sometimes they tilt and float and move
and yet they've memorized this space
just for this season
we made it to the tarmigan island and
stopped for lunch it's a fact of the
world that when you're cold
and outside everything tastes better
I'm eating tea and a poppy seed roll
it's effectively the best meal I've ever
had in my entire life
before heading up the hill Nikolai had
to show me his Harpoon the one he uses
to catch whales
this has been used for hundreds of years
we spent no less than two hours climbing
this island looking for tarmigan
Nikolai casually turned to us and let us
know that this was actually an Inuit
burial ground this is where his
ancestors are
he's going in for the kill
die
[Music]
um
and we had a few close calls with the
time again but in the end no luck
no luck
we're heading back to the Village
with no birds but two seals
so we headed back to the sled and soon
we were Gliding Over the Sea again back
to the Village before the blizzard could
fully hit
him Nikolai invited me to his home where
I met his wife Anna Sophia they fed me
their favorite food from the sea
yes I'm now eating narwhal The Majestic
Arctic whale that I honestly thought was
a make-believe character up until a few
years ago
did you catch this narwhal did you buy
you bought this normal from from someone
else in the village
they call it themselves we'll cut this
normal yourself yeah
and soon we were over in the TV room
looking at the Tusk from the Narwhal we
were eating so it was a big big narwhal
it was big yeah oh I'm evil so dinner
consisted mostly of narwhal meat narwhal
ribs
that's good yeah it's very salty and the
delicacy of narwhal skin and blubber
which is cubed and eaten raw sometimes
with soy sauce here we go
whoa all of this accompanied with fresh
water from an iceberg this this is
melted Iceberg so it's from the inland's
ice from Greenland so you're drinking a
glacier oh lovely
sure
it's really good and to be clear I
wasn't just saying this to be polite raw
whale skin is objectively delicious
now I understand yeah
I had come here thinking that this
community had no other choice but to
hunt during the cold winter and while
they are more limited to their access to
the outside world during these months
this conversation taught me that they
don't just hunt for survival they hunt
because this food this tradition of
being out there on the ice connected to
this volatile weather it's part of what
gives their lives meaning it's part of
their identity
after finishing up with the Narwhal and
seeing more seal clothing I asked
something that had been on my mind for a
while which is how much longer could
this small island and all of its
Traditions survive especially with the
powerful forces of modernization luring
people to the big cities do you think
some of the traditional practices of
hunting and
uh Inuit culture will continue we'll
still be here in 50 years even with all
the modernization
Nikolai and Anne Sophia have three
daughters and they are the ones that
will ultimately answer this question
their oldest daughter who's 19 has
already made up her mind so yeah I'm
curious what your thoughts are about
moving away from you said you didn't
want to leave in my future I want to be
a fisherman like my father you do yeah
ah wow and what about your other sisters
are they do you think they'll be
fishermen too or no no no they don't
want to yes
my little sister she said hell no
oh man so she so she won't be in
tattooed she'll maybe live in Nuke or
something yes yeah like if you want to
be
a nurse
[Music]
I left satut with much more clarity on
what life in a small Arctic Village
looks like how they do it why they stay
and why some are leaving Greenland's
Capital nuke is further south it's a
less extreme climate and it offers
convenience and work work that doesn't
involve breaking into ice looking for
SEALS or stalking Birds up a mountain
one that is not based nearly as much on
Ice that is Getting Thinner and thinner
every year and yet if I learned anything
from hunting on the sea ice with Nikolai
and his daughter it was that these
activities were so much more than just a
means for survival the ice the dogs the
traipsing around a Snowy Mountain where
your ancestors are buried looking for an
Arctic bird this isn't about efficiency
or convenience it's about connection
it's about meaning and tradition it's
identity unlike anything I can relate to
but it's an identity that continues to
be chipped away at and threatened by all
of these forces from the outside world
but this tension is is not new to
greenlanders they've been experiencing
some version of outside forces
threatening their culture for a really
long time for a long time it was the
Danes the colonizers here on Greenland
who came in looking to exploit this land
and to modernize and industrialize this
place and with them they brought
Prosperity economy industrialization new
forms of development income but in
exchange they brought with them an
attempt to eradicate the culture here
forcibly shutting down some of these
settlements pushing the people into
bigger population centers so that they
could work in fisheries and factories
sterilizing the culture and even trying
to thin the population
forcibly stripping away any population
from their land and then separating them
from their friends and family would take
a toll on any people but for a culture
so rooted in their natural environment
this rapid assimilation effort from the
Danes has taken a particularly harsh
toll on greenlandic people very very
fast assimilation that
a lot of people lose their art identity
that was a mental violence so many of
them just chose to become alcoholic to
forget their problems as I moved South I
met up with Pauline a therapist who sees
the effects of this every day
and those problems from back then
continue to many generations many of
them had no opportunity to heal their
trauma even the grandchildren of the
people who were forced to move commit
suicide and have alcohol problems
Greenland has the highest suicide rate
of any place on Earth alcoholism is a
major problem
um
all right
and yet there's hope in this story after
Decades of cultural cleansing and forced
assimilation greenlanders have been
fighting back to regain their autonomy
to regain their culture over the decades
their political system has broken
further and further away from Denmark's
to where they now govern themselves and
greenlandic culture once on the brink of
Extinction is coming back
foreign
[Music]
to see what this looks like I headed
south on a layover in one small village
I found a moment to head down to the ice
to meet up with a group of ladies who
love cold water as much as I do good
morning
[Music]
feels amazing yeah
wow
[Music]
thank you so much thank you have a good
rest of your day
[Music]
I got to Nuke and met up with kupanook a
mining engineer that the world knows
better as the creator of Q's Greenland
where she shares Greenland with the
world in the most amazing way
[Music]
first thing you notice when you get to
Nuke is how many cranes there are okay
so this is definitely not the sleepy
little town that I was expecting this
place is big and it is growing
everywhere I look there's a freaking
crane has Q drove me around we caught a
glimpse of these massive apartment
blocks physical symbols of Greenland's
Colonial past
the 50 60s back then when they come down
small villages and force people to move
to town whoa so they're forced to move
in into those buildings whoa that was
the colonization yes take part of it
yeah so this is the future new
biggest school in Greenland so the
cranes the apartment blocks this town of
20 000 people with all of this rapid
development seemed like a place where
greenlandic culture goes to wither away
to be replaced with supermarkets
shopping malls cars and convenience
with how much Construction they're doing
right now this is likely where nikolai's
middle daughter will end up far from
home and seemingly far from her culture
from the seal pants the days out on the
ice the dogs the Narwhal at least that's
what I thought but after spending a day
with Q I learned that I was wrong
I'm hoping to buy depressed Co meat at
the um
dinner tonight okay
[Music]
first stop in Nuke the butcher I know
what it's like to go hunting for seal
kind of so it's pretty cool that even
here in the city they're doing this
[Music]
soon we were on the outskirts of town
and I was learning just how alive
greenlandic culture was here so we could
actually just hike from my backyard and
then go on and then we'll be able to
find
come again do people still go out and
hunt
even though they could go to the grocery
store it's so much easier we do it
why do you do it go out do all the
effort to get special food
because it tastes really good it's
different it's fresh it's your you know
like the feeling of self providing is so
amazing it's like a must we can't live
without it you can't live without it
here it was again that same sentiment
that I heard around the dinner table in
that Tiny Village there's truly no need
to hunt here and yet the people here
still do do you think that with all this
modernization there's a feeling or worry
that it's gonna dilute or I'm not
worried about the remote places like the
small places I'm definitely not worried
about them I can be worried about like
my children wouldn't learn how to go
hunting fishing and all that but I make
sure that they do they get to try it and
all that we are becoming more and more
proud of who we are how important it is
to keep our own language and all of that
so I think it's just like twisting it
back yeah yeah and are you consciously
doing that with your kids or yes yes yes
in what ways so we only speak green
lantic to them so we are making sure
that they are fully green
land King we have these great abilities
that we should be much more proud of
absolutely that Nikolai was and his
daughter you know his daughter who's
like on Instagram and Facebook and uh
has an Apple Watch but then is out there
with the sled dogs and when I came here
I sort of thought it was one or the
other you either Choose modernization Or
you choose greenlandic culture oh no no
it's
the same time yeah yeah
you can't have both
[Music]
so no nuke is not the place where
greenlandic culture goes to wither at
least not for now greenlanders like Q
live modern connected lives and yet they
retain their connection to the land the
animals the plants and the ice that has
provided for their ancestors for
centuries
that night I ended up at Q's house where
I met her family and watched as she made
soup from that fresh seal we bought
earlier that day another Meal made
possible by the sea ice
[Music]
oh my goodness that is so good good yes
I like seal
hello
[Music]
I never know what
I came here trying to understand how
people survive in remote Villages during
the winter but in the process I learned
several unexpected lessons lessons about
identity and meaning that comes from old
practices lessons about the complicated
nature of modernization and the poison
of forced assimilation
and I left feeling grateful for the
people who let me into their world one's
so different than anything I'm familiar
with
showing me that some traditions are too
strong too valuable to be wiped Away by
modern conveniences
[Music]
foreign